Captain Marvel is back for her first big
screen Adventure since Avengers endgame
and this time we're seeing triple here's
everything you need to know about the
movie from the character story so far to
the people behind the scenes who put it
all together the Marvels has had a rocky
road to theaters originally the film was
said for February 17th 2023 which would
have made it the first installment of
Phase 5 however the filmmakers needed
more time to perfect the film so Marvel
decided to swap the Marvels with Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania pulling the
Ant-Man 3 call from its July 28th
release date and giving it the original
Marvel's Landing Pad of February 17th
however on the very day that Quantum
Mania hit theaters it was reported that
Disney was Shifting the Marvels yet
again pushing it back to November 10th
2023 Studio insiders have said the movie
needed additional time in post
production the MCU was come under a lot
of fire recently for its shoddy VFX work
largely a result of the studios's her
release schedule this decision also
coincided with Marvel Studios president
Kevin feige saying that the MCU would be
slowing down its Disney plus output to
ensure higher quality as well as the
absolute shellacking Quantum Mania
received from critics hopefully this
extra time will give the Marvels a boost
it needs to shine on the screen the
Marvel's boast an incredibly talented
cast needless to say Oscar winner Bri
lson it's returning as Carol dvas before
joining the MCU lson wild critics and
audiences in projects like room
short-term 12 and Scott Pilgrim versus
the world and has since become part of
the Fast and Furious franchise in its
10th installment fast X joining her for
this turn on the big screen is Tiana
Paris as Monica Rambo he was introduced
in one division in addition to her
superhero work Paris has received plaes
for her work in movies like Candyman and
if be Street could talk along with AMC's
madman then of course there Iman velani
who's making her big screen debut as
Kamala Khan Miss Marvel was fi's first
professional acting job and she wowed
everyone as the wannabe superhero but he
will be joining lson Paris and valani in
the film well zi Ashton plays the
story's big bad a cre revolutionary
named darban he may have already seen
ashon in the horror flick velvet Buel
the period drama Mr Malcolm's list or
the British drama D series fresh meat
meanwhile Samuel Jackson will be putting
on the eye patch again to play Nick Fury
movie fans will get another treat in the
form of South Korean actor Park sojun of
parasite who is set to join the MCU
marvelous keeping Park's upcoming role
and wraps but the Marvel's producer Mary
leanos confirmed will be an ally to
Captain Marvel and her new found team
rumors also suggest that he'll be closer
to the former cre Warrior than anyone
would have guessed as he may be her
secret husband but only time will tell
feeling so many feelings right now the
official plus synopsis for the Marvels
reveals that our three leading ladies
are in quite the superpowered
predicament whenever one of these Heroes
uses their powers or three switch places
with one another that's not great in the
best of circumstances it's even worse
when you're dealing with a cre Warrior
armed with the cosmar rod of course the
most important elements of the film will
be the relationship between Carol Camala
and Monica we know Camala will be
fangirling out upon meeting her ID or
Captain Marvel and she'll be pretty
impressed by Monica too as Kevin feige
explained Entertainment Weekly the great
thing about Kamala is that she's not
unlike Tom Hollands Peter Parker and
Civil War she can't believe she's with
these other Heroes and can't believe
that she finds herself in these places
perhaps more interesting will be the
relationship between Carol and Monica
while Captain Marvel was an important
part of Monica's childhood and best
friends with her mom the late Maria One
Division showed us that Monica Harbors
some resentment against Carol for
disappearing from their lives in short
there will be no shortage of cosmic and
personal drama in the Marvels Nea Costa
is making history by helming the Marvels
not only is she the fourth woman to ever
direct an MCU movie but she's both the
youngest person and the first black
woman to do so dasta made a name for
herself by directing the crime drama
little woods which starred Tessa
Thompson and Lily James and won the
Norah Efron prize at the Tribeca Film
Festival she then impressed haror fans
by directing 2021 Candyman reboot based
on a script co-written by horror Maestro
Jordan Peele now she finds herself
handling the challenge of making a
Captain Marvel sequel or trying to
balance screen time between three leads
duster elaborated on this a bit to
inverse saying a lot of what we've been
thinking about is what part of the
journey do we need to see for each of
them how do we honor the part of the
story that at in terms of the cannon
while also within our story making them
equal Thea also revealed why she's the
perfect pck for the upcoming flick it's
because she loves this stuff she told
inverse I like to call myself Marvel
trash actually my friends call me that I
will go see all the movies even if it's
bad I'm like well there are some good
things about this I grew up with the
comics I grew up watching the Spider-Man
cartoon and the Fantastic 4 I knew a lot
about the Marvel Universe in general
just like it sometimes takes a team of
superheroes to tackle the problem
sometimes it takes a team of
screenwriters to produce the best
possible story for proof look no further
than the Marvels which boast three
scribes ping the script one of the
screenwriters is director Nea deusta and
she's joined by Megan mcdonal who became
a Marvel darling after her work on
wonder Vision as a member of the writing
team McDonald is the one who came up
with the ship of thesias conversation
between vision and white vision and
she's also working on the upcoming
Agatha darkhole Diaries the third writer
in the room is Alyssa carasik who worked
on the Disney plus series Loki notably
the episode The variant where the god of
mischief and Mobius search through
different apocalyptic events on the hunt
for a murderous Sylvie Zar Ashton is
making her MCU debut as the villain
darbin a cre revolutionary AR Warrior
who Wants Revenge on Captain Marvel
what's interesting about this casting is
that darb Ben is historically male in
the comics but Marvel does updated the
character to produce a superhero film
with four female leads however many of
Dar Ben's core characteristics and
motives are taken straight out of the
comics Darin's hatred of Captain Marvel
whom she calls the annihilator comes
from Carol's actions after
1995 by defeating the Supreme
intelligence she destabilized the cre
Empire which seems to have left a power
vacuum but the fanatical darban is ready
to end the ongoing cre civil conflict
and rebuild the Empire's Legacy and she
is willing to wage an Interstellar War
to do it she's targeting every planet we
call home unfortunately in the comics
darb Ben succeeds with this plan though
his Reign is short lived however this
doesn't mean the same is in store for
Ashton's iteration of the character
having been reimagined for the big
screen means a new plotline is fair game
to the Marvel's film will pick up in the
immediate aftermath of the Miss Marvel
post credit scene where Kamala Khan
suddenly vanishes from her bedroom and
is replaced by Carol dvas setting up the
events of the upcoming film as for Carol
herself we were introduced to the
superpowered Space Ranger in Captain
Marvel where she initially operated as a
cre soldier named viz after crash
landing on Earth and running across Nick
Fury she slowly learned her true
identity that the cre were manipulating
her and that her sworn enemies the
shape-shifting Scrolls were actually
victims in need of a hero after coming
into her full potential and defeating
the Carol joined the Avengers in
Avengers endgame and played an
instrumental part in defeating Thanos
during the Battle of Earth meanwhile One
Division reintroduced Monica Rambo who
was last seen as a child in Captain
Marvel Monica returned from the snap and
went back to work at sword but she
became a key player in dealing with W
maximoff along the way Monica gained
superpowers of her own after saving the
town of Westview she was approached by a
squirrel agent and asked to join ni Fury
in space the former director of Shield
had been spending his time in the the
cosmos however the Marvels is set after
his return to Earth in secret Invasion
one of the biggest questions going into
the Marvels is what has Carol Damas been
doing since 1995 even her reappearance
in Avengers endgame didn't give much
away thankfully the official synopsis
for the upcoming movie gives us a big
hint noting that while Carol has
reclaimed her identity and defeated the
cre Supreme intelligence un intended
consequences see Carol shouldering the
burden of a destabilized universe the
movie is expected to be set in 2025 so
Carol has now been flying around the
universe for 30 years as secret Invasion
revealed she and Nick Fury ultimately
failed in their mission to find the
Scrolls a new home but it sounds like
Captain Marvel has dedicated herself to
other worthy fights instead after all
shouldering the burden of protecting the
entire universe also seems like the only
conceivable reason that Carol has been
so absent from Maria and Monica's lives
it also seems likely that Carol will be
holding tightly onto a few secrets from
those missing years as well it's even
possible that she got married it's
highly speculated that Park so June's
character will be Prince Yan the ruler
of a musical planet where the
inhabitants communicate through S this
marriage is something that hails from
the comics and even if it is just a
front for a temporary Alliance Carol
having a husband is definitely an
interesting twist for someone so
insistent on going it alone while Iman
valani Kamala kham will be ecstatic to
meet a longtime hero and namesake
Captain Marvel Tiana paris's Monica
Rambo will likely be less than
enthusiastic about reuniting with her
estranged Aunt the relationship between
Carol and Monica was revealed in one
division having been a victim of
thanos's snap Monica returned 5 years
later to discover her mother Maria had
died from cancer now she's dealing with
some serious grief as well as anger
towards Carol for abandoning her and her
dying mom the problems between them will
be tricky to navigate and there no easy
fix for either of them especially Monica
however the movie synopsis also teases
us along with with Kamala this unlikely
Trio must team up and learn to work in
concert to save the universe as the
Marvels so it sounds like saving the
world together might just be what these
two need to start working through their
issues higher further faster the Marvel
star Brie lson has addressed her fate in
the MCU ahead of the upcoming film after
it was reported that she signed a seven
picture deal with Marvel this suggested
that Carol danas would be sticking
around to save the Galaxy for a long
time but Lon has something different to
say on the subject responding on Twitter
she categorically denied the claims and
later said that she had no idea if a
character would even appear in future
MCU Vehicles this leaves Carol's fate
uncertain with two young superheroes
ready to take up a mantle should Dar Ben
succeed in her Mission meanwhile
kamala's appearance in Avengers Secret
Wars is seemingly confirmed so we can
expect to see this young super hero
survived her encounter with the creek
revolutionary and returns soon but what
about the third member of the s unlike
fani Tiana Paris is not currently slated
to make another MCU appearance at this
point however with Carol probably
feeling some guilt that her best friend
died while there was nothing she could
do it seems unlikely she's about to let
anything happen to her niece if she can
help her she could even sacrifice
herself to protect Monica but here's
hoping all three leading ladies make it
out
[Music]
alive